les chiffres ne sont pas encourageants
on s'aperçoit qu'on va bien vers une
quatrième vague d'hospitalisation pour
les adultes et pour la première fois
depuis le début de l'épidémie les bébés
seraient plus sujets aux infections du
coït 19 on estime qu'entre 40 et 60% des
enfants pays ce qu'être positif alors
est-ce que le covan 19 est devenu plus
dangereux pour les bébés avec le variant
delta on y répondant facture
[Musique]
il est désormais avéré que l'apparition
du variant delta est une des causes qui
contribue à une plus grande contagiosité
de la population à l'heure actuelle ils
représentent près de 95 % des infections
au co vite 19 en france il contamine
plus de monde et touche une fourchette
de population plus large comme on peut
le voir sur cette courbe les jeunes qui
étaient pourtant peut contaminer l'année
dernière à la même période ne sont plus
épargnés et quand on parle de jeunes on
inclut aussi les bébés c'est le pédiatre
philippe barbe chef de service adjoint
aux urgences pédiatriques de l'hôpital
lenval à nice qui a lancé l'alertent
auprès de nos confrères de nice matin
[Musique]
bon ben on joue pas on a quatre enfants
cinq mêmes dont deux béliers mais
comment explique-t-on la contamination
des enfants aux causes id alors qu'il ne
l'était pas au début de l'épidémie
finalement lors du premier ont finement
et de la première vague on avait des
enfants qui étaient positifs mais tu
étais asymptomatiques qui n'avait
atteint que là ce qu'on constate c'est
que ceux qui sont positifs ils sont des
symptômes est donc essentiellement de la
fièvre pour les tout-petits lorsque vous
avez un bébé de onze jours de vie ou de
1 mois et demi deux mois qui a de la
fièvre effectivement ça peut amener à ce
qu'ils viennent consulter aux urgences
et cette augmentation des cas de covin
dès le plus jeune âge inquiète certains
pédiatres il y a un an ont comptabilisé
20 patients qu'ovide hospitalisées entre
0 et 9 ans aujourd'hui ils sont 53
d'après santé publique france au delà
d'une infectiosité plus importante de ce
variant ce qui peut expliquer les
nouveaux cas chez les nourrissons ce
sont les parents toutes ces affections
elles viennent de parenté me dire que
c'est pas les enfants qui se contaminent
entre eux c'est vraiment pas contaminer
les parents peuvent être des vecteurs du
virus
et quand on regarde les courbes de la
vaccination par classe d'âge on remarque
que les personnes de 49 ans et moins
sont celles qui sont le moins vacciner
pour l'instant concernant la vaccination
des femmes enceintes ce n'est que le 20
juillet que son application a été
recommandée les taux de vaccination des
futures mamans ne sont donc pas encore
très élevé alors c'est bien sûr la
solution ça continue à faire un très
peur c'est autorisé même tout à fait
recommandé dès le deuxième trimestre
sans risque pour le bébé est ce un acte
aime beaucoup beaucoup de données parce
que beaucoup de patientes ont été
vaccinés avec des enfants qui vont bien
ce qui est rassurant et il faudra si tu
peux même c'est que parce que l'on à la
constater c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
formes graves chez les bébés mais comme
symptôme ça donne de la fièvre et des
difficultés alimentaires avec
éventuellement même de la diarrhée
gloire des vomissements donc quand un
bébé entre aux urgences pédiatriques les
médecins s'assurent qu'ils s'alimentent
correctement si ce n'est pas le cas les
médecins auront recours au gavage pour
que les prenne sa ration alimentaire
quotidienne
le problème c'est aussi que c'est les
enfants qui peut
contaminer l'entourage les
personnels donc assise toute mission
veiller ainsi mis en isolement c'est
compliqué aussi pour eux mais le plus
souvent ces enfants qui évolue
favorablement encore une fois il n'ya
pas de forme grave
des formes qui nécessite le recours à la
rénovation même si les formes graves du
co vient de chez les enfants en bas âge
sont très rares pour l'instant la
propagation du virus qui risque d'être
inquiétante une projection de l'institut
pasteur publié fin juin précise que
d'ici septembre une contamination sur
deux pourrait survenir chez les mineurs
et c'est ici que se pose la question de
la vaccination pour les enfants
pourrait-on envisager de vacciner les
bébés avec la société française de
pédiatrie
le comité de vaccination et la haute
autorité de santé effectivement on est
en train de réfléchir à l'indication de
la vaccination pour les moins de 12 ans
alors jusqu'à quel âge pour l'instant
cela est en réflexion jambes
[Musique]